et on continue avec sylvain odette qui
est membre associé de la chaire de
recherche en gestion du secteur de
l'énergie bonsoir monsieur odette
bonsoir est-ce que l'évaluation
2,65 pour ça c'est ce sera officialisé
dans les prochains jours c'est ce sera
probablement sa 2,6 2,7 pour cent oui
oui moi les calculs j'ai fait j'avais
besoin 2006 2007 ça dépend de ce mois de
septembre on n'a pas encore la venue
parce que le calcul se fait maintenant
sur l' indice de l'inflation moyens
qu'on compare par rapport à l' indice de
l'implosion moyen de l'année précédente
se terminant à la fin du mois de
septembre c'est ça
exactement c'est exactement ça dont on
va parler 12 mois de l'année précédente
avec les blues - de la victoire c'est
terminé ben c'est pas unanimes et on
calcule d'octobre à septembre deux ans
qu'on parle de la variation pourcentage
de ces deux héros et donc cette formule
là monsieur date c'est celle qui est
adoptée depuis la décision du
gouvernement en 2019 de fixer les
hausses de tarifs à l'inflation
expliquez nous pourquoi on a fait ce
choix là et comment on l'a fait
saviez vous sa vie du fameux débat sur
les écarts
les écarts de revenus qu'on avait par
rapport au coût à chacun et c'est normal
d'avoir des écarts de revenus par
rapport aux cours mais là ça fait trois
quatre ans que hydro-québec distribution
avait des écarts positifs donc c'est à
dire que les tarifs étaient fixés un peu
plus plus élevé que nécessaire pour
couvrir les coûts dans une unique donc
c'est là que tout le débat est il
vraiment du bon on le qualifiait sur de
trop perçu et puis là votre enquête est
arrivée première année d'application de
la loi 34 jeunes et là n'est pas ali
tarifs qu'on a en ce moment il ya une
hausse au 1er avril 2021 de 1 3% et la
prochaine hausse en vertu de cette loi
là serait au 1er avril 2022 et cela
qu'on parle de 2 7% à partir du 1er
avril 2010 alors on voit dans ce cas là
puisque l'inflation générale augmente il
ya une poussée inflationniste
présentement mais s'entraîne aussi les
tarifs puisque on lit à l'inflation est
ce que est ce que le gouvernement
prenant cette décision la cave était
quand même très critiquée rappelons le
en 2010 neuf est venu un peu déconnecté
l'évolution des tarifs des besoins réels
d'hydro-québec
oui c'est certain qu'ils aient des
allemands il faut regarder les traits sa
sert a quoi sa sage à générer des
revenus pour couvrir les coûts d'un
service dans ce costume d'un service
public de distribution d'électricité et
inclut le transport et la production
donc il faut que les tarifs soient fixés
d'homère à s'assurer que ont recours les
coups qu'on a besoin pour offrir le
service à la population en fonction de
nos besoins et nos attentes
donc est ce que ça veut dire qu'on s'en
va qu'est-ce que là on est à 2-1 que 65
x et l'an prochain avec l'inflation qui
en demande on pourrait à trois ou à
quatre pour cent est ce qu'on s'en va
vers d'autres trop perçu
une bonne question parce qu'on ne sait
pas maintenant depuis qu'on a retiré ses
traits sont 70 à la régie de l'énergie
on peut pas savoir si oui ou non l'écart
entre les coûts et les revenus qu'on
accepte son grain ou son corps est coupé
au québec il dans la grande question qui
se pose en ce moment c'est qu'on est en
transition énergétique on veut litres
électrifier les transports et les basm
est ce que ces trois pour ça qu'on a
besoin pour investir aujourd'hui dans
des bornes de recharge
augmenté notre électrification plus
rapidement possible d'ici 2035 et
peut-être que en fait avec les
investissements qu'on a à faire pour
faire la transition énergétique c'est
peut-être pas suffisant donc l'idée
c'est que l'inflation n'est peut-être
pas meilleur éducateur pour nous
permettre de réaliser la transition
énergétique dans le futur pour le québec
mais
je comprends mais on nous a présenté
cela comme étant des économies que nous
allions faire un la reformulation
tarifaire en fonction de l'inflation
était présenté comme étant des économies
ce que vous décrivez là nos besoins
faudrait être capable de savoir en
quelque sorte le calcul est vraiment et
ce serait la régie de l'énergie nom qui
pourrait faire sa ba je sais pas si cela
régis berger ou dont québec où le
gouvernement met à deux questions qui se
posent quant au fait que les kinois se
rend compte que là
c'est une diversion de dire est ce qu'on
devrait augmenter à l'inflation pour
l'inflation c'est quel est le
pourcentage sur les dix prochaines
années d'augmentation devraient avoir
pour réussir cette transition
énergétique là moi j'ai pas cette
réponse l'homme est peut-être qu'on sera
capable cette réponse est est ce que
chaque québécois de me dire écoutez pour
réussir cette transition énergétique la
marque à chaque année vous acceptiez
d'avoir 50 dollars de plus sur votre
facture d'électricité ou non peut être
100 dollars de plus je sais pas s'il va
falloir qu'on paye 50 $ de plus 2% ou
100 dollars de plus 5% mais la question
qui va faire se poser c'est comment ça
va coûter cette transition énergétique
là parce que évidemment des
infrastructures a payé et peut-être que
les tarifs sont trop bas peut-être
qu'ils sont trop élevés pour le moment
il n'y a pas de processus pour savoir il
répond de cette question mais c'est
quand même complexe pour le citoyen qui
voit l'inflation énergétique
présentement qui voit l'inflation
générale il ya comme une poussée
d'inflation énergétique en ce moment est
ce que c'est le cas
oui qui causaient votre me suis montré
tout à l'heure je n'ai entendu dire que
c'est sûr que à la base c'est le baril
pétrole votre collègue m'a interviewé
mardi dernier à ce sujet et c'est sûr
que ça ça pousse à la hausse toutes les
prix de l'essence donc l'inflation ce
moment elle est beaucoup poussé par le
prix du baril pétrole qui lui poussent
les prix de l'essence
ok on va s'arrêter là merci pour cette
explication on verra dans les prochains
jours la décision de toute façon à
propos des tarifs d'électricité merci
monsieur au dot un tiroir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit